next franklin d roosevelt's 1933
presidential inauguration this
inauguration was the last one held in
march
the 20th amendment fixed inauguration
day in january
this is about 20 minutes
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you franklin teleno roosevelt
do solemnly swear
that you will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of your ability
preserve
protect
and defend
the constitution of the united states
so help you god
i franklin delano roosevelt
you solemnly swear
that i will faithfully execute the
office of president of the united states
and will to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states so
help me god
[Music]
mr president justice
my friends
this is a day of national consecration
and i am certain that on this day my
fellow americans
expect that on my induction into the
presidency
i will address them with a candor
and a decision
which the present situation of our
people impel
this is preeminently the time
to speak the truth
the whole truth frankly and boldly
nor need we shrink
from honestly facing conditions in our
country today
this great nation will endure
as it has endured
will revive and will prosper
so first of all
let me assert my firm belief
that the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself
nameless unreasoning unjustified terror
which paralyzes needed effort
to convert retreat
into advance
in every dark hour of our national life
a leadership of frankness and a figure
has met with that understanding and
support of the people themselves
which is essential to victory
and i am convinced that you will again
give that support to leadership
in these critical days
in such a spirit on my part and on yours
we face our common difficulties
they concern thank god
only material
thing values have shrunk to fantastic
levels
taxes of risen
our ability to pay has fallen
government of all kinds is faced by
serious curtailment of income
the means of exchange are frozen in the
current trade
the willard leaves of industrial
enterprise lie on every side
farmers find no markets for their
produce
and the savings of many years and
thousands of families are gone
more important
a host of unemployed citizens
face the grim problem of existence
and an equally great number toil with
little return
only a foolish optimist can deny the
dark realities of the moment
and yet our distress comes from no
failure of substance
we are stricken by no plague of locusts
compared with the perils which our
forefathers conquered
because they believed and were not
afraid
we have still much to be thankful for
nature still offers a bounty and human
efforts have multiplied it
plenty is at our doorstep
but a generous use of it languishes in
the very sight of the supply
primarily
this is because the rulers of the
exchange
of mankind's good
have failed through their own
stubbornness
and their own incompetence
have admitted their failure and have
abdicated
[Music]
practices
of the unscrupulous money changers
stand indicted in the court of public
opinion
rejected by the hearts and minds of
men true they have tried
but their efforts have been cast in the
pattern of an outward tradition
faced by failure of credit
they have proposed only the lending of
more money
by which to induce our people to follow
their false leadership
they have resorted to exhortation
pleading carefully for restored
confidence
they only know the rules of a generation
of self-seekers
they have no vision
and when there is no vision the people
perish
yes the money changers have fled
from their high seats in the temple of
our civilization
we may now restore that temple to the
ancient truth
the measure of that restoration lies in
the extent to which we apply social
values
more noble than mere monetary profit
happiness lies not in the mere
possession of money it lies in the joy
of achievement in the thrill of creative
effort
the joy the moral stimulation of work
no longer must be forgotten in the mad
chaste of evanescent prophets
these dark days my friends will be worth
all late foster
if they teach us that our true destiny
is not to be ministered unto
but to minister to ourselves to our
fellow men
recognition
of that falsity of material wealth as
the standard of success
goes hand in hand with the abandonment
of the false belief that public office
and high political positions
are to be valued only by the standards
of pride of place and personal profits
and there must be an end
to a conduct in banking and in business
which too often has given to a sacred
trust the likeness of chalice and
selfish wrongdoing
small wonder
that confidence languishes
for it thrives only on honesty
on honor
on the sacredness of obligations
on faithful protection
and on unselfish performance without
them it cannot live
restoration calls however
not for changes in ethics alone
this nation is asking for action
and action now
our greatest primary task is to put
people to work
this is no unsolvable problem if we face
it wisely and courageously
it can be accomplished in part
by direct recruiting by the government
itself
treating the task as we would treat the
emergency of a war
but at the same time through this
employment
accomplishing great greatly needed
projects to stimulate and reorganize the
use of our great natural resources
hand in hand with that
we must frankly recognize the over
balance of population in our industrial
centers
and by engaging on a national scale
in a redistribution
endeavor to provide a better use of the
land for those best fitted for the land
yes the past can be helped by definite
efforts to raise the values of
agricultural products
and with this the power to purchase the
output of our cities
it can be helped
by preventing realistically
the tragedy is the growing loss through
foreclosure
of our small homes and our farms
it can be helped by insistence
that the federal
the state
and the local governments act forth with
on the demand that their cost be
drastically reduced
it can be helped
by the unifying of relief activities
which today are often scattered
uneconomical unequal
it can be helped by national planning
for
and supervision of all forms of
transportation
and of communications
and other utilities that have a
definitely public character
there are many ways in which it can be
helped
but it can never be helped by merely
talking about it
we must act
we must act quickly
and finally in our progress towards a
resumption of work
we require two safeguards
against a return of the evils of the old
order
there must be a strict supervision
of all banking and credits and
investments
there must be an end to speculation with
other people's money
[Applause]
and there must be provision for an
adequate but sound currency
these my friends are the lines of attack
i shall presently urge upon a new
congress
in special session
detailed measures for their fulfillment
and
i shall seek the immediate assistance of
the 48 states
[Applause]
through this program of action
we address ourselves to putting our own
national house in order
and making income balance outgo
our international trade relations
though vastly important
are in point of time
and necessity
secondary to the establishment of a
sound national economy
[Music]
i favor
as a practical policy they're putting
our first things first
i shall spare no effort
to restore world trade by international
economic readjustment
but the emergency at home
cannot wait on that accomplishment
the basic thought that guides these
specific means of national recovery
is not nationally narrowly nationalistic
it is the insistence
as a first consideration
upon the interdependence of the various
elements in and part of
the united states of america
a recognition of the old and prominently
important manifestation of the american
spirit of the pioneer
it is the way to recovery
it is the immediate way
it is the strongest assurance that
recovery will endure
in the field of world policy
i would dedicate this nation
to the policy
of the good
neighbor
the neighbor who resolutely respects
himself
and because he does so
respects the rights of others
the neighbor who respects his
obligations
and respects the sanctity of his
agreements
in and with a world of neighbors
if i read the temple of our people
correctly
we now realize as we have never realized
before
our interdependence on each other
that we cannot merely take
but we must give
as well
but if we are to go forward
we must move as a trained and loyal army
willing to sacrifice
for the good of a common discipline
because without such discipline
no progress can be made
no leadership becomes effective
we are i know ready and willing
to submit our lives and our property
to such discipline
because it makes possible a leadership
which aims at the larger good
this
i propose to offer
pledging that the larger purposes will
bind upon us
bind upon us all
as a sacred obligation
with a unity of duty hither to evoke
only in times of armed strife
with this pledge taken
i assume unhesitatingly the leadership
of this great army of our people
dedicated to a disciplined attack upon
our common problems
action in this image
action to this end
is feasible
under the form of government which we
have inherited from our ancestors
our constitution is so simple
so practical
that it is possible always to meet
extraordinary needs
by changes in emphasis and arrangement
without loss of essential form
that is why
our constitutional system has proved
itself
the most superbly enduring political
mechanism the modern world has ever seen
it has met every stress a vast expansion
of territory
of foreign wars
of bitter internal strife
of world relations
[Music]
and it is to be hoped
that the normal balance of executive and
legislative authority
may be fully equal
fully adequate
to meet the unprecedented task before us
but it may be
that an unprecedented demand
and need for undelayed action
may call
for temporary departure from that normal
balance of public procedure
i am prepared
under my constitutional duty
to recommend the measures that a
stricken nation in the midst of a
stricken world may require
these measures
or such other measures
as the congress may build
out of its experience and wisdom
i shall seek within my constitutional
authority to bring to speedy adoption
but
in the event that the congress shall
fail to take one of these two courses
in the event that the national emergency
is still critical
i shall not evade the clear course of
duty
that will then confront me
i shall ask the congress for the one
remaining instrument to meet the crisis
fraud
executive power
to wage a war against the emergency
as great
as the power that would be given to me
if we were in fact invaded by a foreign
fall
for the trust proposed in me
i will return the courage and the
devotion that best fits the time i can't
do no less
we face the arduous days that lie before
us
in the warm courage
of national unity
[Music]
with the clear consciousness
of seeking old and precious moral values
with the clean satisfaction that comes
from the stern performance of duty by
old and young alike
we aim at the assurance of a rounded
a permanent
national life
we do not distrust
this the future
of essential democracy
the people of the united states
have not failed
in their need they have registered a
mandate
that they want
direct
vigorous action
they have asked for discipline
and direction under leadership
they have made me the present instrument
of their wishes
in the spirit of the gift
i take it
[Music]
in this dedication of a
nation we humbly ask
the blessing of god
may he protect
each and every one of you
may he guide
in the days to come
[Music]
you're watching american history tv on
seaspen 3.
coming up next is american artifact